hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome to four last things now this
game is a point-and-click adventure game
that features some Monty Python misc art
Oh beautiful Renaissance paintings ah
culture art the game of life being
played out in front of us such a
beautiful experience that uh oh
I'm liking it less I'm liking it a lot
less you know I'm liking it I like it
not oh hello hi uh oh we got oh no what
are you doing to that Apple over there
hi okay all you need to do is avoid this
forbidden fruit don't listen to him eat
the apples oh don't you dare eat those
apples God our God look at you that's
our Lord God Almighty the eternal
omnipotent creator of everything he's
slightly less inspiring and majestic
than I'd anticipated okay
violence is nothing okay all right I
think I'm gonna eat one of the forbidden
fruits I don't think I'm going to eat
any of the forbidden fruits thank you
buddy 1 God God hey listen buddy God God
I'm gonna eat one of the forbidden
fruits don't know how to tell you this
but I just feel like it's in my destiny
do not else you shall be banished from
this earthly paradise if if you thoughts
apples you'll feel the wrath of God
that's me no way to stop this insane
music eat the flippin apples hey Eve
karne dude I will smite the crap out of
you of you touch those apples OTO even
the creepy serpent child thinks you
should eat one all right well lobby
freakin da let me ponder
my choices I shall look on the horizon
and ponder in infinity what I shall do
stop pretending you have options here
hey Eve
that's Eve her face her hands are sticky
with dried in apple juice and she smells
fantastic
alright violence is not the answer I
think I'm gonna eat one of the forbidden
fruits excellent all right
hmm let me look at these wait Han hello
hi this creepy servant child seems
pretty keen on feeding me these apples
I'd rather take one of the fresh ones
off the tree I'm not gonna snaffle the
apple straight
why don't you snaffle the Apple that's
the forbidden fruit of the tree of the
knowledge of good and evil looks
deliciously ripe my controller vibrated
why are you okay hello what's happening
I don't know where I am
hello hi how's it going okay alright
this is beautiful
what's happening oh hi okay excuse me
while I cut in line don't mind me
hi help please help okay I have sinned I
have done the most terrible things I
must give confession from my vile deeds
immediately what sins have you committed
old man all of wonderful terrific all
seven marvelous and in which of the
parish boroughs which sins committed it
mainly Nuremberg in Lubec but I've
committed lust in almost every harbour
town south of Oslo ah oh dear I see I'm
afraid Nuremberg in Lubec don't fall
within our jurisdiction
we can't take confession for sins
committed in another parish why on earth
not severely lust is lust wherever it is
committed yes we are all capable of
forgiving you but it's against the rules
as you can see from the cue this is a
very busy church we have to stick to the
rules so what am I to you
we could tell him about the loophole no
no no we can't tell him about the
loophole
what's the loophole ah well yes as we
mentioned we can absolve you of any sin
but we can't let you confess sins
committed outside the parish borders if
however you were to commit each sin
again within the parish borders then we
could absolve you of everything you
can't possibly expect me to commit every
file deed again no no not every deed
every sin a confession of lust covers
all lustful acts commit each of the
seven sins in this parish and your
absolution will be absolute okay I think
I can imagine okay all right I think I
understand how this games gonna go off
you pop all right happy sinning Oh Oh
all right try not to murder anyone don't
freak out okay all right hello hi
innocent-looking young lady that's one
tight corset okay
I would never strike a lady my staff
violence what sins are you seeking
forgiveness for wrath I slit my father's
throat for using a rude word what was
the word I shall entropies it okay
harmless simpleton what a friendly
looking oaf what sins are you seeking
forgiveness for gluttony yum yum yum
okay what sins pride I committed the
great valorous deed of murdering a
thousand innocent men in a single battle
which was great of course but then I
made the mistake of bragging about it in
a brothel the following evening they
ratted meat into the local clergyman
before I'd even
unbuckled my codpiece let's see what
sins greed as you can see I enjoy the
finer things in life and lots of them
all right what sins she is a virtuous
angel she is here only to support my
quest for absolution I fornicated with
the stableboy alrighty then she's a
hottie she's a hottie hottie sorry I
thought it would be fun
it wasn't I'm sorry okay hello they look
happy enough sure okay what sins my wife
is guilty of sloth she spends her days
in bed reading romantic novellas eating
the food I earned for our family she
refused even to trouble her legs and
making way to this church and you I've
committed Envy by wishing I too could
afford such a lifestyle ah - beautiful
organist performing a slightly clunky
rendition of Lois
Nicole's clamber oh it's sweet that you
share home okay all right good job
Bravo all right okay I'm out of here
goodbye All Right see ya Oh who's uh
who's here hello hi how are you hi hello
he seems pretty engrossed in whatever
he's writing
okay can I slap him this poor sap must
have suffered enough torment in his time
okay hello hello what are you writing
about I'm writing a poem about inspiring
beauty of God's green earth okay will
you write a poem for me I don't take
commissions I write because my soul
requires it of me I need to write as
other men need to eat and have write
only of the things that inspire me to do
so if you show me something that
inspires me to write a poem then I shall
write a poem for your coins I will do no
such thing
okay all right stuck up your own ass a
bit but that's all right
what inspires you I am inspired by God's
most beautiful creations especially the
pretty ladies my finest works or poems
about love all right off you pop then
hello hi old man with pig hello I have
no wish to talk to you boy
fair enough see you around the bed buddy
all right hey okay that's that's bizarre
all right okay it's a bunch of yokels
having a singsong and a floating egg all
right we're gonna pretend that's normal
all right now I'm gonna take my LSD and
carry on my way can I touch them wait
Bravo Bravo okay all right
okay that's all there is to that then
what is happening here hello
all right creepy weirdos a surgeon
wearing a funnel hat on a fat man
receiving you on earth at the thighs
brain surgery
lady with a book on her head standard
stuff okay alrighty then I don't I don't
even want to know what that's all about
alright hello hi were you guys we're the
obligatory Kickstarter backers what's
Kickstarter it's a crowdfunding platform
used to God by God to help fund the
creation of this world I'm pretty sure
that's blasphemy alright what are you
doing here
we're just chillin doing fun operations
ruining the artistic integrity of the
game is getting dangerously meta I'm out
here alright wait can I get a speaking
part too geez what a bunch of shameless
attention seeker he's better just lying
around in the mud hello hello they're
fine for now huh what are you doing down
there
we've eaten our fill and drank our wine
skins dry and now we are simply resting
friend don't you have work to do we're
all landowners not workers of the land
our time is mainly spent in leisure ok
alright then can I join you between us
we own many acres of land but none of us
hold claim the over that spot by the
tree oh all right I guess this is how
it's gonna be I'm Audi yeah move go over
here now okay maybe I'm not oh yes I am
excuse me what about this lady churning
butter and a giant butter churning well
hello
okay fine see ya I'm gonna go commit
some lust Oh I walked into the weird
part of town peep here huh
I'll peep okay I'll beep oh hey
a beautiful woman reclining on a bed of
plump white pillows and lady how you
doing my name is markiplier I'm a pretty
big deal in YouTube I've got a lot of
subscribers how you doing she's stunning
she's magnificent she's surprisingly
clean hello there young lady
alright get out of here you dirty dog I
am a man sir yeah
all right well then it says P pair a
statue of a merry peasant is it is that
is that the Mary is that the married
this guy or all right hello some
strange-looking horn players Tooting at
a fairly somber rendition of Giovanni
kava-kava Chios Khan's an alle forest
hello this guy this guy I don't want to
put him off his rhythm you go girl
man with pipe okay man smoking a pipe I
think if you touch me I'll twist your
thumbs off oh hey buddy they're easy
hello
who do you want um you smoking or eating
pours - a straw smoking can I have a
puff get your own you dang codger
smoking is bad for your health
boy to be that guy owes wise mouthing
strangers okay alright this was an
enlightening conversation I see a
slightly old looking vegetables mmm
that's a lot of slightly old looking
produce can i pill for some hey you
can't just pilfer my pills like that
well piss off wine shops I'm terribly
sorry
but I'm starving in penniless I have no
choice okay okay you can have some just
this once
thank you I've got some slightly old
looking vegetables hello excuse me yes
can you spare me something to drink not
if you ain't got coins can you spare me
something to sneeze into not if you
ain't got coins eat
okay I'll be off then yeah can I steal
something to sneeze chisel and mallet
was that okay it's mallet and chisel all
right I've got those good good good what
do I do with them what do I do
hey this guy you keep dancing this guy
you have a good time this guy
sinister-looking
well this guy is a bigger schnoz and me
he has a face like a half-consumed
Volk Aryan but he plays that loot like
an angel Bravo
I was this one gonna be Dingle dangle
Dingle Dingle dangle great ok great
wonderful I'm really happy about what
are you two doing up there what are all
of you doing up there
why are there two people in one hoody
that doesn't make no kids it's two
people in one hoody this guys having a
great time
what are you doing blacksmith how are
you doing are you doing colorfully
dressed blackface sitting at some sort
of grinding wheel all right Oh what was
that for it's keeping you on your toes
oh okay thanks hello hello where are you
then on the blacksmith and make metal
into different shapes for living all
right how's the blacksmithing business
it's a tough time for a true artisan
like me I'm capable of forging the
finest suits of armor and the sharpest
swords but this area is enjoying a rare
period of sustained peace all anyone
wants around the earth
al flagons and piss pots so I waste my
time forging beautiful works of art that
no one will buy or waste my talent
making that for the local drunkards and
only the latter option pays Oh boohoo at
least you have a job sorry I don't often
get a chance to vent okay how much metal
could a blacksmith Smith if the blacks
my terrible you're thinking of
woodchucks ok bye for now this was
insightful and I hate you All Right see
ya what's in here whoa aah that baby I
don't like that baby dancing baby how
you doing from my only point of
reference for this image is the dancing
baby and the whimsical late 90s TV Comi
but this is a respectable game I only do
Renaissance art Monkey Island and
obscure literature references so I have
nothing to say about this baby man I
gotta say every single time I walk in a
new room it is a goddamn treat that is
just there's just something that cannot
be beat
oh it's a lute
can't get to it can I talk to it ok ah
creepy lawyer hello this guy looks like
a real creep looks like the type told
agree
all right what's all this then these
lucky people just inherited a large sum
of money after the death of a relative
to whom none of them had a particularly
strong emotional connection how lovely
filling out the paperwork for him for a
small fee of course
we're gonna be flapping wrench yes we're
planning to extort the crap out of them
they have no idea just how much they've
inherited these people don't know how
many coppers make a silver nevermind the
worth of the ten thousand hectares of
bare barley filled with some careful
manipulation of the figures I should be
able to pocket at least three quarters
of their fortune okay
can I help you can actually I'm having
trouble locating a copy of this town's
official treachery deceit and extortion
regulation without them I'm only
sanctioned to actually fraudulently
and/or fallaciously which will much less
profitable in this instance okay if you
can find me a copy I'll give you a cut
of our ill-gotten gains where can I get
a copy of that town then the clerk's
office next door should be able to give
you a copy but they seem extremely
reluctant to offer any help okay can you
give me some legal advice what do you
need to know I can a church forgive
someone of sins committed out of with a
church parish that's not a legal issue
I'm afraid okay how about if I murder a
child in a force but there's no one
around to hear it is it still crime yes
okay how about can photographic images
of public domain artworks earn a new
copyright there's a more complicated
issue than you might imagine
okay all right I'll leave you two isn't
this all a bit dishonest yes you have a
problem with that yes actually I do piss
off then do-gooder okay all right good
I'll see you around the bender then I
don't know what the hell is happening oh
oh oh I don't know what's going on back
here but it doesn't seem good and I
don't like none of this okay this guy is
just pure vomiting at least it's chalice
to piss off okay how rude okay how rude
is it the monkey - damn monkey monkey
hello some kind of security system
judging by the ball and chain I imagine
he's not very happy with the arrangement
okay all right who's a good monkey how
about I hammer and chisel your ball and
chain noob that ain't happenin this
doesn't need to be chiseled or mounted
okay wait on way I'm a double click this
okay all right let me see if this will
do it monkey you want some food yeah all
right doc hey Doc hey Doc excuse me I'm
a little busy at the moment
I have sick people to treat hmm okay all
right I don't know what's going on here
I'm out here all right I gotta find
another area some that is piss that is
straight-up piss what's this hello I'm
gonna take this and I'd be too
distracted by this bear Willy to
maintain eye contact during the
conversation I don't want to seem rude
and or pedophile II okay all right see
ya all right what's goin on over here
uh-huh okay fishermen hi how's it going
fishing is a sacred act performed by two
men who love each other very much
the delicate balance of this manba man
bonding experience should never be
disturbed my dog looks depressed oh I
want to get bitten can I talk to you dog
woof woof ship of fools some
surprisingly buoyant fool singing
Claudio Monteverdi steer see and Chloe
okay and that guy's getting bashed in
the face with a pot good job whatever
you doing Bravo I'm very proud of you
Bravo okay all right Bravo I only sing
instrumentals I don't like the ones with
words in because they're always trying
to mean something
ooh you don't get in line portrait
painter what the hell is going on
underneath your skirt I don't even want
to know okay all right what the flip bro
not cool I'm sorry I'm slapping a blind
man I don't know why all right excuse me
hello
are you really blind best question to
open with best question yes are you
really a portrait painter yes will you
paint my portrait of course please put
two copper in the tin you don't have a
ten okay then just put them in my pocket
then I don't have two copper then you'll
have to come back when you do all right
what if I already did will you pay my
portrait you don't have a ten I already
did no you didn't I'm blind that stupid
comeback okay challenge the pie King for
seven pence a big pile of dents
meat-filled pies okay keep your grubby
paws of my pies hello piking how are you
doing
slappa slappa my grandmother slapstick
hero part is harder than that okay how
about this hello puny old man are you
ready to challenge the pie King what are
the rules two men two pies first man to
eaters pies the winner what's the prize
in the extremely unlikely event that you
beat the pie King you will
you win the pie king's crown in title
you will become the new pie king and you
will have earned the right to ridicule
and shame me in any manner you see fit
all right I'm ready
excellent the wagers seven cents I don't
have that then you'll have to come back
when you do all righty then Oh aah Oh
huh
all right that is weird don't know what
to make of that but ok hello it's
probably a union issue all right they're
embroiled in a serious knife bat jug
fight okay all right I'm going up here
then hello oh he's beautiful he's
flipping beautiful God God can you part
the clouds real quick I need some advice
All Right see ya I guess that's
beautiful statue it's a statue of a fat
dwarf riding a donkey I love it okay oh
it's the it's all the paintings used in
the game oh my god oh it's all the
paintings used I don't want to know
where that's coming these are gonna be
spoilers if I don't know where they are
two more normal-sized man and a tiny one
I wonder what they're whispering about
okay okay good boy good boy good boy
good boy that's a good boy right there
all right
excuse me I do like them slapos
okay all right good job then all right
elderly violinist a friendly old
toymaker giving Johann Sebastian Bach
sonata number one his best shot good job
Bravo a painting of such a beauty and
complexity you can't even begin to
describe it where am I going
why am i over here I'm gonna go this one
oh hi hello okay alright I'm out there
so what am I supposed to do that is the
question of the day this game is
fascinating
this game is legitimately fascinating I
have no idea what to make of it
it's uh to give you a little background
of it I was perusing my recommended list
on Steam and this one popped up I like
it a good bit I like it a good bit but I
need to find a whole bunch of [ __ ]
excuse me yes my child what do you want
now why is this church so busy people
love doing sins but they hate feeling
guilty and remorseful they also had
taken responsibility for their own
actions and apologizing and making
genuine attempts at self-improvement
okay oh and we released vast quantities
of dangerous seas to burn off our cloud
cover and bathe ourselves in divine
looking shaft of sunlight yeah okay
explain to me again we'll have to repeat
all my sins
we can't take confessions okay can I
come and give a confession now you
haven't committed any valid sins yet you
need to repeat all seven before we can
let you in off your palm okey-dokey then
ah here we go more more more MORE oh
wait wait wait go back go back I don't
leave this place anyway hello hi
unhealthy looking drunkard how you doing
what is it then are you an oh is that
your dog and as much as a man can have
ownership over a beast of any nature no
it is not Dericks
okay you enjoying your rail no very much
thanks it's empty as a hollowed goose
arse I have never heard that expression
and I never want to hear it again ah you
look unwell are you okay I got syphilis
and playing in a pinch of typhus as well
as everything else you might not wish
for wisely only thing that scares off
the devil is al what makes me piss like
a horse with fire only less casual ain't
got no more ale neither so nope not okay
I guess okay all right
I should think it's about time too if I
wasn't already half around the tree
I don't know what you're talking about
or what that means I do not like this
place yeah I don't like this piano lady
looking at me like this man with pipe
talk e-excuse me sir what I sure wish I
could be as happy as content as one of
these couples I bet you - oh I'm envious
all righty then okay all right there we
go we're good we're good we're good all
right that was depressingly easy uh
excuse me sir
all right I wish I could be dumb as
uncomprehending as those children or
dogs I bet you do what I wish I could be
as creepy looking as tobacco stinky as
you man Google Google wolf wolf
Tim dabba doo bro yo Verde a good job
Bravo okay all right
this was weird I don't know why I went
in here but I got an achievement so
cross that bad boy off the list I guess
okay um I guess I guess I guess that's
enough for one episode this game is so
bizarre I've never seen a game like this
I mean it's a point-and-click adventure
game which are fun but this one is just
uh this is a flavor of something special
the likes of which wait was this door
hang on
oh hi this some sort of magician okay
all right then well I'm gonna walk out
i'ma walk out all right see you guys so
I'm gonna face this up in another
episode so thank you so much for
watching let me know what you think of
this game it's really funny I like it
it's charming in a weird way that I
haven't seen in a long time and uh silly
and I like that so thank you everybody
so much for watching let me know
anything down the comments below and as
always I will see you in the next video
bye-bye